ああ
あの辺実用な人どれくらいいますかなんかこの季節台風とか低気圧がすごくて今日朝
起きてからずーっと頭が痛くて何か今は漱石トンカチがあればあっ
あったはを例えてて本当にトンカチであったバブ調理台ぐらい頭が今痛いでございます
外れそうです
ダメでも喋っても痛いあのちょっと本当にしゃべると頭にき微分立常盤金に行きますよ
と思いますかね3に迫ったんですけども結構デカイことです今日は後
珍しく売れずらしく事務所の方から
始めたみたいな一さんちょっとちょっと今一つといえばいいみたいな感じできますて
すぎなんだろうと思ってそれがそこにありますちょっと開けてみますね1回あの名前は
書いてなかったで作り3型の人がわからなかったっけ
ホンダ医大が届けたんだろうって感じで好きくまさんのシールとね
乳業カードが入っていますね裏にはず紙が入っています
パットにすごいカードが入ってます手紙はちょっと最後にしますちょっと見ていきます
ねこの中に結構
友情カードだけどものすごいハーピースペっドラムは
オシリスの天空竜あ売りやだ兄弟みたいなカードが入ってるバスゲーム2チラシてる
なぁ
ネット s ブラックメタルドラゴンレッドアイズブラックドラゴン組み上げたら
ドラゴン
すごい泥棒パレードやあー3人のパッケージをタップマジチャンジャンウスケブラ
トランスジェンダーあるじゃん
どこかで買ったなこれとか買ってくれたのかなますけどなぁ
米ブライズ青いディスクだすごいめちゃくちゃくれてんじゃん
[音楽]
voodoo j
car
って頭って改めてバーン頭痛が痛いと動いてねこれこれすごいんですよ
ちょっと待って蛇ですがいろんなカードを受けてくれたんですけどもこれはちょっと
本当にあの本としちゃってこれマジで送ったのを何度上で送ったの
いやっ
あれ空これはちょっと撮影に取り上げるべき代物かなと思いまして取り上げてしまい
ますねこれ
まあ言いを知ってる人なら知ってると思うんですけども2人の想像せ follow
アクティって言うカードでやっぱりよこれお値段を聞くとみんな
-4この感じですな強いカード競技じゃないんですけども水に入るであっえっと現在全
世界に1万枚しかないカードです
レアさすがに僕はちょっとあのもらって溜まってるわけでも行かなかったんでちょっと
動画にしてしまいました
これ淡いよ本当にもう見た感じわかると思うんですけどもうすぐ神々しいんですよね
カウントつタイプ悠遊カードと言い出すにサインとか書いてないんですけどもほら来て
に火災が炊いてあるという
あっはっは
おったまげしさしぶりにずっとん
動揺しましたこれだと言ったってこれ千葉 amazon 上だとすらべてみましょう
かあんなにもらった番手談とかすらべたい服はないんですけどもうこればかりは
ちょっと価値がすごいねど amazon にもほらプティみたんですけどもう一番
安くてこれならば5000円ですよええ
いやこれ送った人がじゃ何考えてるのいやありがとうございますありがとうございます
のですけどもなんかコンプ付撮っていい
いいのかなっていうもらっちゃっていいのかなと思ったんですけども誰から送られてき
たか分からないんですよねどうしようもないんで
明け方をいただきますで本当にも大切にしますありがとうございますで問題が手紙です
ねこの1位ってどういう意図でこの頭いた一体この人はどういう人で僕にほら来て送っ
たのかっていうのはこの手紙に書いてありますごめんねちょっと
送ってくださった方申し訳ないんですけども名前も変えてないのでちょっと
4座いますねはじめシャツを様こんにちは
乳業カートで赤い竜のカード
ほしいと youtube で言っていたのでネットで探しました
遊戯王のことはよくわかりませんがとにかく流のカードを買ってみました
頑張ってください
4日
それで買ったのよくわかんないけど流のカードを買ってみたって言って掘られて買っ
てるのかな
うわ薄者うわぁ
ありがとうございます赤い竜のカードを見つけたのですが黒と青もあったので買ったの
でプレゼントしますアウトだなこの人は嫌がらせに負けずに頑張ってください
ファンで応援しています体に気をつけて元気で笑顔で言ってください
冬季から始めが幸せになるように毎日神様に乗っていますそれでは
[音楽]
本当にありがとうございますあの全部うれしいんですけども
じゃああーよってとてもうれしいです本当にありがとうございますけどあまり個で多分
価値がわからなくて買ったのかもせんねんですけどもうちょっと
ねっヤバイっすよやばいすん受け取って僕も嬉しいんですけども
ちょっと立タズしてしまうんですけどもまぁ本当にでもありがとうございます
俺これどうすればいい世界に立真ん前しかないカードの1枚が僕の手元に来てしまい
ましたびびった書を送ってくださった方の最もまた面白いですねよくあんな形で上の
カードを沢山送ったんですけどもその中に不動産紛れて世界に1万枚のカードが入って
いたという
旅棚に飾っとこう
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ